[موسيقى]
سجن تدمر انقطاع التامه عن الخارج نهائيا
لا جريده لا كتاب لا راديو لا حتى قلم او
ورقه ممنوع كل هذا الموضوع
انقطاع تام نهائي عن الخارجي وصل بكم يوم
في احد الايام من مواسم الرياح المغبره
التي هبت في سجن تدمر الصحراوي عندما علقت
جريده
جريده صفحه من جريده عند الشراقه المفتوحه
وكنتم تتمنون الا تذهب بها الرياح بعيدا
بالكامل كل الناس اللي موجودين بالمهجه
انظروا معلقه بالجريده طبعا في البدايه
كان الدعاء وابتهال انه علا وعسى تنزل
لحاله يعني على المهجر خوفا من اي حركه
يعني يقوم فيها سجناء وانه الحارس ما يحس
فيها وانه الحارس ما يحس فيها نهائيا يعني
لكن رؤيه ما يحصل في معرفه ما يحصل في
الخارج او رؤيه لانه معظمهم كانوا متعلمين
كلها الشغلات يعني الحرف المطبوع بحد ذاته
وانا هيك حكيت يعني الحرف المطبوع بحد ذات
بحد ذاته صار له سحر خاص
انه حصه الواحد على الفطور
ربع رغيف مع ست حبات زيتون المفروض البيضه
تقسم على اربعه بالخيط بيقسموها
كل اربع اشخاص بيطلع لهم بيضه واحده يعني
ايوه يعني المعتقلين
[موسيقى]
واحد 400 واحد حسب العدد بيطلع واحد فيهم
او المعتقلين ان يضعوا اياديهم في الشوربه
المغليه
هاي حاسه تكررت طبعا تكررت كتير يعني
[موسيقى]